колись за часів Соціалістичної німецької
Демократичної Республіки в цьому лісі
проживала партійна еліта очільник НДР
ері хонекер та міністр держбезпеки Еріх
мільке мали в цьому Лісовому поселенні
свої резиденції сьогодні ж вхід сюди
відкритий тут працює клініка де пацієнти
проходять реабілітацію і нині проживають
українці вони опинилися тут через війну
а житло їм надала
Утім деякі українці знайшли в цій
клініці не тільки прихисток а й роботу
клініка берлін-бранденбург стала мабуть
одним з найбільших роботодавців для
українських біженців у Німеччині тут
працевлаштували аж 40 втікачів від війни
в Україні працювати українським біженцям
тут вигідніше аніж лише отримувати
соціальні виплати від
держави серед тих хто знайшов тут роботу
Лариса горай разом із сином вона
поселилась в одному з корпусів на
території клініки в березні 2022 року а
вже через місяць почала працювати в
кафетерії лікарні без знання німецької
мови ну поначалу было тяжело Вы знаете
почему спочатку знаєте було дуже тяжко
тому що коли Нам запропонували за
контрактом тут працювати ми були
здивовані Адже ти ще не знаєш мови але
Попри це Нам запропонували і сказали що
в процесі роботи все одно автоматично
набагато швидше вивчаєш мову ніж коли
просто ходиш на інтеційні курси Хоча
вони у будь-якому разі потрібні та
необхідні они в любомлуча
[музика]
нео ми отримуємо їжу в таких боксах ми
спускаємося вниз на кухню внизу в нас
основна кухня для всіх чотирьох поверхів
у цих боксах нам видають їжу на кожен
повер поначалу было
коне
Всё правильно нем это очень пунктуальны
дуже пунктуальні люди чітко за часом
якщо вечеря о 5 годині вечора то о 17й
чітко Має бути все накрито все
засервіровано ідеально должно быть всё
накрыто всё засервировано
идеально у Києві жінка мала невеликий
манікюрний салон працювати в кафетерії
для неї новий досвід Лариса каже що за
півтора року змогла заговорити німецькою
Угу для меня это большой в жизни опыт Я
хочу сказать для мене це великий досвід
у житті щодо роботи Мені подобається с
початку був страх як я з цим пораюся А
зараз для мене Це наче
моєю с СЕС меня это настолько словно моё
то есть вообще вот в своей тарелке у нас
вчера мужчина заехал 29 года рождения
року народження йому 94 роки я підбираю
їм естраду 60х 7х на телефоні
вмикаю а вони з таким задоволенням
смакують їдять взагалі просто наче
дрібниця здається А ще я їм вмикаю
італійську естраду то їх потім Спробуй
попросити щоб вони пішли Але ж
задоволені бранденбуркий реабілітацій
центр почав приймати українських
біженців одразу на початку російського
вторхнення в Україну тоді тут Поселилася
близько 200 українців клініка одразу
запропонувала їм роботу і паралельно
вчити мову на
курсах спочатку українців
працевлаштовували терміном на рік але
декому вже навіть вдалося отримати
постійний контракт важливою ланкою у
комунікації між керівництвом та
українськими біженцями стала Оксана
Жолудь так само як і інші українські
біженці від війни Вона опинилася в
гуртожитку клініки навесні Минулого року
одразу після приїзду спочатку на
волонтерських засадах а потім з
офіційним контрактом вона почала
перекладати з англійської інформації від
керівництва реабілітаційного центру для
українців зокрема і про наявні вакансії
і ми цю інформацію доносили так до людей
що є такі такі-то вакансії в таких-то
секторах і ви можете всі зацікавлені ви
можете залишити свої координати і з вами
потім зв'яжуться і вже буде далі
процес Ну налаштовуватись там чи трудові
договори чи як керівництво Бранденбург
клінік воно
е всі люди
вони були зацікавлені також допомогти і
допомогти з працевлаштуванням також
Тобто всі бажаючі які хотіли знайти
роботу вони в принципі її знайшли в
різних секторах звичайно але вони
знайшли їх спочатку всіх взяли без
знання мови Так але в принципі е у всіх
була умова що вони мають відвідувати
курси німецької для того щоб і полегшити
собі в першу чергу життя тому що дуже
складно працювати Якщо ти не розумієш що
відбувається Оксана теж почала вчити
німецьку з нуля каже що англійської мови
яку вона знала до переїзду в Німеччину
вистачало лише на початку роботи через
півтора року Оксана вже отримала
необмежений у часі робочий контракт
жінка стала тим ланцюгом який забезпечує
зв'язок між адміністрацією клініки і
українцями вона вирішує питання
пов'язані з біженцями і
працевлаштованими в клініці українцями
за словами Оксани її робота триває по
суті 24х7
фактично мій робочий день він
починається він триває взагалі 24 години
він починається о 5тй ранку фактично так
тому що я маю поїхати відвести свого
сина в садочок але все одно мій
мобільний телефон є у всіх тому якщо у
когось щось трапляється вночі то в
принципі Да я отримую якесь повідомлення
в кращому випадку або дзвінок Ну що це
за питання це там починаючи з заповнення
якихось антрагів закінчуючи розбіром
пошти реабілітаційний центр запропонував
українцям різні вакансії клініці
насамперед були потрібні люди які
допомагають подавати обіди пацієнтам а
також у галузі прибирання та садівни
доглядальниками за пацієнтами українці
тут не працюють Адже для цього необхідно
зробити так званий аусбільдунг пройти
спеціальні
профкурси українці задіяні тут лише як
помічники деться про мінімальну допомогу
у догляді як от прогулятися з пацієнтами
якщо їм потрібна допомога З пересуванням
або нагляд за пацієнтами які втратили
пам'ять аби ті залишалися на території
клініки під час прогулянок деякі
українські біженці працюють на рецепції
Анастасія сичева з Дніпра працює у
відділі неврології Я сразу вже Була Я
одразу була готова до того що хочу вийти
на роботу Я вже досить добре розумію що
мені кажуть я
впораюся раніше Анастасія працювала в
супермаркеті німецьку Вона вчила в
українській школі але каже що заговорити
змогла лише коли закінчила інтеграційний
курс тут у Німеччині в нашем чате
написала нденбург написали що сюди
потрібен рецепціоніст Я якраз їхала на
мовні курси у потязі Я одразу подумала
що тре насати сразу подумала нужно
написать тепер серед основних завдань
Анастасії Зустрічати нових пацієнтів і
показувати їм
палати для начала я прихожу
Найперше я приходжу і розкладаю газети
наші пацієнти дуже люблять читати потом
включаю компютер захожу включаю компютер
і дивлюся Скільки нових пацієнтів
надійде слько пацинтов поступает
новых записую щоб коли вони приїдуть я
знала куди мені треба провести
пацієнтівкуда Мне нужно показать
провести
пациента за словами Анастасії вона
чудово розуміється з пацієнтами і
відвідувачами
клініки з деякими пацієнтами в неї
навіть зав'язалася приязні дружні
[музика]
стосунки я можливо не можу відразу
відповісти але дуже добре розумію все що
мені
кажутьря син Анастасії навчається в
спортивній школі 13тирічний хлопець
футболіст і проживає в спортивному
інтернаті у Франкфурті на Одері на
вихідних Він приїжджає до батьків
Анастасія з чоловіком нещодавно також
переїхали з гуртожитку в окреме житло
робота їй подобається і шукати нову
жінка поки не планує э бота Очень
равится мені Ця робота дуже подобається
я хотіла би далі вивчати німецьку мову
бо можливо хотіла би пройти
провкурси Я ще не знаю які плани бо дуже
складна
ситуація потому что сложная ситуация але
ми плануємо із сімєю залишитися тут
здесь в
Германии як і Анастасія майже всі
українці яких працевлаштувала клініка
працюють не за фахом зараз це люди
бухгалтери
Так це люди навіть з юридичної
освітою з економічною освітою ну тобто
це люди взагалі з дуже різних скажем є В
кого В кого є вища освіта в кого середня
Але все одно всі ці люди в принципі в
основному працюють не за фахом та і сама
Оксана журналістка За освітою працює не
за фахом у секретаріаті клініки а також
секретарем у школі на базі клініки де на
медсестер і доглядальників вчаться люди
різних національностей ця школа
знаходиться у приміщенні добре знайомому
Оксані адже Саме тут вона разом з
п'ятирічним сином провела перші місяці
свого перебування в
Німеччині Ну ось тут кімната в якій я
проживала коли жила в хаймі скільки е
шість
місяців перші шість місяців Коли я
приїхала я проживала в цій
кімнаті тоді у цьому гуртожитку заселили
понад 130 українців нині залишаються
лише близько
50 працевлаштованим у клініці українцям
з пошуком житла допоміг роботодавець
хтось як Оксана Переїхав з гуртожитку в
квартири в містечку бернау хтось у
будиночки і кімнати в корпусах на
території самої клініки житло
працевлаштовані в клініці українці
оплачують самі і зарплатні через рік
після переїзду до Німеччини до Оксани
приїхала Її мама пані Надія колишня
продавчиня Сьогодні вона як і донька
також працює в клініці у кафетерії для
пацієнтів що в Україні працювала що тут
буду
працювати
скучаю в мене син залишився в
Україні Так що Так таки
життя дуже важке для України но ми
пам'ятаємо і не знаю як всі а всі
українці хочуть повернутися в Україну ви
теж плануєте та та
обов'язково багато рідних всі лишились в
Україні така доля розкидала всіх по всій
Європі по Америці
і дуже я дуже надіюсь що скоро
закінчиться воно і що ми
повернемся якщо б роботи не було я б не
видержала я вам зразу говорю робота
наскільки емоційно заспокійли заспокоює
ти в Русі ти В роботі ти забуваєш А це
головне пані Лариса Яка теж працює в
кафетерії також мріє повернутися додому
Там на неї чекає ший
син я б уже давно вернулась Я вже давно
повернулася
б якби не старший син Він у мене
військовий йому післязавтра до речі Буде
лише 22 будет время когда я дам команду
знаете как военный человек знаєте Він як
військова людина Каже Мамо коли я дам
команду тоді
повертатиметеся а наразі оскільки він
любить свого молодшого брата каже поки
що з малим вивчайте німецьку мову і
тіште мене тим що живете там де нема
сирен і вибухів тому якось так поэтому
как-то
так